je suis vraiment désolé quasi mais on ne
retrouve pas cette botte d'oignons je
suis sûr que j'en avais pourtant tu peux
vraiment pas tant mais non un
sandwich à la confiture de prunes et au
camembert sans oignons mais c'est comme
un jour sans pain ou un gloubi boulga
sont si ce que tu ne retrouve pas les
oignons jean-françois
bonjour julie vous excusez moi facteurs
nous saluent casimir ya plus de nyon
mais non c'est kinect ce n'est pas qu'il
n'y ait plus d'oignons mais si je ne
sais plus je les ai mis cela dit
monsieur campagne s'en moquent
éperdument sommes pas du tout pas du
tout non je n'ai justement vous demandé
un sandwich au pâté de foie avec de
l'oignon femme parce que moi aussi
gentil que ça va alors c'est bien ma
veine vous mangez les oignons sans
confiture de prunes vous mais de
préférence ou les bas c'est dégoûtant
vous avez vraiment des goûts bizarres
chacun son opinion casimir moi je ne
discute pas tes nous mais je puis
affirmer que je passe pour un des plus
fins gastronomes de lille je crois même
que j'en suis le plus grand mangeur vous
le plus grand mangeur de lille
ben tu peux rire voici tu crois que tu
es pas de quelqu'un avec ton tentant
gouby boga et ben tu te trompes j'ai
gagné trois fois tu m'entends trois fois
le concours du plus gros mangeur de
choucroute oui bien alors les autres
avaient déjà mangé un souvient alors il
n'aimait pas la soupe notation
je
lui parle du
sujet je vous en prie
chacun prétend qu'il mange plus que
l'autre eh bien nous allons organiser un
grand concours de choucroute
bon pour sa stalle bien ça va gagner ces
facteurs et serviettes
fourchette versa c'est bien adorer les
six nations ah non de françois à je lis
est ce que tu pourrais apporter un peu
de sauce tomate asos com a tout de suite
donné la sauce tomate dans la choucroute
ouais c'est dégoûtant sa
merci
ces bouquets ça met de la couleur
voilà que
d'imiter ses murs
ça y est au pays des weppes bon alors
est un surnom à temps oui non non on ne
peut pas manger de la choucroute à la
sauce tomate sans fruits confits
jamais vu quelqu'un manger un plat ou
aussi écoeurant comme ça voilà les
fruits confits on ça va être excellent
je préfère ne porter deux mois de crise
voilà beau et bien casimir je pense que
comme ça on va pouvoir y aller attention
au printemps sur vous et moi
c'est pas tout c'est pas possible je
vous dis il me faudra aussi le yaourt le
tuc en doute dans la choucroute et puis
les anchois
c'est un choix les quatre
les quatre la confiture de groseilles à
oublier malades
voilà les jolies petites gens soient
satisfaits de moi la groseille tu me
mets qui me mêler car s'il te plaît
voilà grosso
attention ou là ne vais pas trop qu'on
dise ici c'est bien voilà
bon alors quasiment comme ça je pense
que ça suffit on va peut-être pouvoir y
aller non non ça va quasi mais attends
tu as tout non en forêt et aux havrais
[Applaudissements]
va nourrir
julie à propos qui est chargée de
nettoyer le jardin aujourd'hui à temps
il faut que je continue le calendrier
qui établit l'ordre viennent organiser
le spot hier c'était moi aujourd'hui
c'est monsieur du snav au parfait ce
sera encore du travail à faire
quasiment
pas mme
kazemi aussi 3 qu'est ce que ça c'est
mon journal ouais et alors bah dis donc
j'ai pas fini de le lire du poète en
coinçant j'ai nommé ne t'énerve pas
sierre ici alors à m il m'a l'air
devient de résumer aujourd'hui
quasiment droite qu'est ce que c'est tu
nous as même pas dit bonjour bonjour tu
dis bonjour casimir
et coutu embêtant aujourd'hui un bonjour
françois ça va très content bon puisque
c'est comme ça moi je te dirai plus rire
casimir white qu'est-ce que ça est
pourquoi tu jettes des papiers partout
comme ça ah bon alors toi aussi tu
prends parti contre moi bon ce que je
vis en personne ne prend parti contre
toi bon alors laissez-moi faire mon pic
nic 30 c'est pas une raison pour mettre
des papiers partout c'est un chacun le
jardin nettoyer chacun son tour 1 et
aujourd'hui c'est à monsieur lui snav ce
qu'ils ignorent c'est dans l'ombre un
sympathique d'accord un fromage
voilà les eaux dur
les thomas a le gobelet
voilà enfin julie julie qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire mal je ne vois pas mais en
tout cas ils exagèrent vraiment
regarderai plus de voler un autre
tablette soit les assiettes et à pour
monsieur ghislain arabe aux formations
du snarr pour monsieur lisnard
voilà
ça c'est pour monsieur du snav
les ennemis et dure quasiment raté ce
passage tu le fais exprès jeter des
papiers par terre huawei alors mais tu
sais que c'est un monsieur du snob de
faire le nettoyage qu'il aura beaucoup
de travail
ah ouais et alors vous tuez train
d'autres sans gêne why et alors
casimir white est ce que ça y est tu as
vu dans quel état d'ivresse jardin ouais
et alors et bondir un dépotoir aux
écoutes voyons françois ne te fâche pas
puisque c'est une farce que je fais à
monsieur de ce noble puisque aujourd'hui
dans notre organisation c'est à lui de
nettoyer le jardin très franchement
casimir moi je trouve pas que ce soit
une très très bonne idée de force
vous êtes vous amuserez lui arrive venez
vous asseoir me disent représenter
l'état il y aura
c'est une histoire stupide figurez-vous
que j'étais chez les jeunes excellente
amie à moi qui fais les tableaux
extraordinaire en lançant des assiettes
sur des planches enduite de colle forte
c'est sublime tout à l'heure ils me
montrer quelques unes de ses oeuvres
lorsqu'elle me disent tous deux je vais
vous montrer ma dernière elle va vous
tapez dans le et brusquement je me
retourne et blanc elle était juste
derrière moi et il nous a vraiment tapé
dans l'oeil on peut dire oui j'ai une
grosse bosse sur le front est ils
aillent au beurre noir
mais ce qui me désole le plus c'est que
j'avais une réception mondaine avait des
gens très importants
aux manettes il faut rentrer chez vous
et vous faire soigner par un médecin
on n'est pas le médecin mais pourquoi ou
fait des piqûres j'ai horreur des pics
non je me suis dit il ne faut pas se
conduire comme en est d abord allez
venez et puis aucune raison pour que
l'on fasse des piqûres aller qu'on
croyait mais j'en suis sûr moi allez
tout à l'heure j'en ai pour une minute
vous vous souvenez bien
mentionné chelala
casimir qu'est-ce que ça revient s'il te
plaît ainsi à qui la tue c'est le
règlement sur les nettoyages du jardin
ou un et alors quand quelqu'un nous est
malade c'est celui du jour d'après qui
prend sa place à loin et tu sais qui est
inscrit pour demain ben oui ouais non
non c'est toi et à venir qui ça moi howe